question how many tubes of red lipstick
have you gone through here oh man
I have a huge drawer full of lipstick so
I go through quite a lot probably not as
much as everyone thinks I don't cut I
definitely go through a lot of things
because you've perfected that out of why
are you aggressive with it too like I
put it on hard so it's a very thick
layer oh it would have much more than I
need well what I was actually gonna see
if you could help me do is how I could
get into the Miranda mindset of things
that was wondering if you could kind of
walk me through things that I need to do
yeah in order to achieve I totally okay
great well the first thing I kind of
mean is looks safe of course which I
believe I have all right I think so oh
my god you want to look you can do it
I'm not gonna do it today I never
answered today but do you want me to
turn into lab first you need that the
lipstick this is the most important
thing okay usually I'd save it for last
but today we're gonna go for it first oh
right I guess I just want to see what
the lipstick on as soon as possible all
right usually you just do the bottom lip
kind of normal kind of and I kind of I
mean like it goes outside of the lines
quite a bit and then the top and you
just go above the top lip line now this
is the key you go like when you do your
lip there you go yeah you got like
really good it over yeah oh great a
little bit oh it feels it feels so good
no that's right
that's okay all right so now we need the
bobby pin okay you got to go with the
temple like where your your your
hairline goes back the farthest okay and
really accentuate that forehead oh love
it because Miranda is so expressive with
her forehead yeah
you still look beautiful this is what
bothers me is that when I do this I look
terrifying and you still look cute I see
right now do I take a look you you look
good but here we're not yet not yet my
face okay okay show me the faces you
gotta tilt tilt your head inside okay
it's going your eyes
I know all right so oh that's good eyes
oh I love it oh I'm feeling so beautiful
yes perfect
so uh you can take over my job now no
I'll stay here with your interviews and
you can go do these haters back off if I
find that day in the life of Miranda
what would I be doing as Miranda of
course probably eating lots of meat and
I feel like this is like the perfect
Halloween costume yeah like it takes
very little effort all you need is a
button-down sure I already feel so
beautiful yeah then I just like this is
great yeah you look perfect
thank you very much hey don't forget to
subscribe to EJ's YouTube channel and
I'll see you next time